>> I think India will become one of the leading
economic superpowers of
the 21st century just behind China.
Actually, I think India will catch up with
China in terms of growth
rate, not infrastructure, but growth rate
within the next 3 to 5 years.
I think the danger for India is that it becomes
complacent and the
rising India, shining India story makes the
establishment in business
and political terms too come placement and
self-satisfied, because
there is a tendency for the Indians to think
that everything is fine
and they don't need to worry about the rest
of the world.
I think the truth is that India is showing
under Anand Sharma, the new
Commerce Minister, that it wants to engage
in the G-20 on the Doha
round.
Prime Minister Singh is taking his rightful
place on climate control
and others who's in the Copenhagen talks.
I think India will become a responsible and
more important player in
the G-20 which will be the new global directorate
for new economic
policies setting.
So do I think India will become a superpower?
Define superpower.
As among the fastest-growing, strongest economies
on the planet in the
21st century? Yes.
Militarily? No.
Although it is a nuclear member -- member
of the nuclear club.
But let's call it, rather than superpower,
let's call it one of the top
three economic players in the 21st century.